y se cumplió el peor de los pronósticos
en cuba un tercer tanque de combustible
se incendió en el puerto de matanzas en
el occidente de la isla esto luego que
el viernes un rayo incendiar a un primer
tanque del que es el mayor depósito de
combustible de cuba el incendio que
aseguran que comprometió entonces el pez
el tanque que ahora está incendiado de
la manera que se había visto
anteriormente funcionando como un
pebetero lente o por favor el domingo en
la noche un segundo tanque se vio
también envuelto en llamas ahora los
vertidos de esta nueva explosión ha
reavivado el fuego de los dos depósitos
anteriores está la situación que
habíamos muy complejo
un cristal que encendido porque además
vuelvo este combustible en el 1 la
función entonces también como otro otro
fuego 1 a que está ahí en de grandes
dimensiones
este incendio ahonda en un problema de
escasez de combustible que vive cuba el
gobernador de la región y el propio
presidente miguel díaz canel reconocen
que supondrá un problema a largo plazo
lo que hay que seguir comprando y
dedicándole poco financiamiento que
tenemos para garantizar a nuestro pueblo
la la mínima energía que eso sea un
problema que tenemos y que como se dijo
por nuestro presidente no a corto plazo
a las labores de extinción se sumaron el
domingo efectivos llegados desde méxico
y venezuela por el momento el incendio
se ha cobrado la vida de un bombero y ha
dejado al menos 16 desaparecidos y 125
heridos todo ello en medio de un déficit
energético que organismos oficiales
cifran en un 35 por ciento para este
lunes